[Music]
[Applause]
but you know what
[Music]
[Applause]
bum-rushing the tan again they are plumb
rushing the tent look at this
[Music]
look at this
[Applause]
[Music]
running out of there now
the question is stay on stable down
there already boots it
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
I would truthfully
brainy
hey hey you guys are a bunch of
you're with our ability
to make a living for our families like
you are you have the right to be here
absolutely one with yourself like you
drew out the right here and we have the
right to organize get the out of
our seat get out of our lives
to make baby from my family
are you so concerned upon my union you
guys have the choice to not join my
union and not be Amanda my
that's your joints you have a short
later can you write to be here yes
itself the people anyway walking City
Michigan
[Applause]
Hey
you